there's simply no way to tell you how
insane
this story is without screaming and
going crazy but i'm going to try to do
it while while sort of remaining calm if
if it's possible
uh donald trump the president of the
united states who
lost the november election by a lot to
joe biden and is scheduled to leave the
white house in a month
had a meeting at the white house this
weekend where he discussed with lawyers
declaring martial law and forcibly
seizing voting machines see how calmly i
said that
the calmness with which i said it has no
connection whatsoever to the complete
and utter insanity and depravity of the
situation
and considering martial law isn't the
only thing
that donald trump did during this
meeting trump
is considering naming that complete nut
lawyer
sydney powell she's the conspiracy
theorist attorney
who trump said just weeks ago has
nothing to do with anything he's doing
trump is considering naming her special
counsel
to oversee a supposed voter fraud
investigation this is the same woman who
said that there's a venezuelan plot
also involving antifa george soros
and a guy named eric coomer to steal the
election
trump is considering naming her special
counsel
trump and rudy giuliani want the
department of homeland security to
seize voting machines to examine them
and some of donald trump's lawyers and
if chief of staff
his chief of staff said you know you
actually can't do that
now at one point in this meeting when
people were telling trump
the things you want to do are against
the law
sydney powell reportedly started
chastising them saying that they were
quitters
they were unwilling to do what needed to
be done when donald trump was told
you know department of homeland security
they can't just go and seize voting
machines legally from the states
trump suggested what if i sign an
executive order to seize the voting
machines which trump's lawyer pat
cipollone
said yeah we also can't do that and then
yes donald trump asked the team about
imposing martial law
as suggested previously recently by
donald trump's indicted
and later pardoned former national
security adviser michael flynn who
during a recent appearance on newsmax
said trump should declare martial law so
this is where we are right now
this is now the insane situation
in which we find ourselves the president
is actually thinking
and saying out loud to lawyers what if i
impose martial law to avoid having to
admit
that i lost the election in order to try
to steal it
and meanwhile the trump administration
is saying that it's bad that a biden
advisor used a bad word last week
can you can you imagine everything is
backwards trump
wants to look at seizing voting machines
people around trump are telling him bad
idea it's illegal
and trump considers naming the woman
they recently said
had nothing to do with them to oversee
all of this and you know what's really
insane
when word of this and other harebrained
plans
previously have leaked a bunch of
trump's followers
react uh and they say oh you know this
is
uh this this is to the they don't
instead of saying
wow that's too far that this even this i
voted for trump but even this is too
much
they react by saying you know if trump
is thinking of doing this
it must be part of some brilliant plan
because trump always has something up
his sleeve trump
he must be playing 4d chess remember
benghazi
and the 11 congressional hearings that
were held to look at what crimes hillary
committed
which turned out to be none there have
been no
hearings over trump's complete
mishandling of the pandemic
in which more than 300 thousand
americans have died and there is no
discussion at least right now
about wait a second if we had 11
hearings over benghazi
shouldn't we be looking into what the
president is doing
talking about martial law seizing voting
machines and a special counsel
to investigate non-existent voter fraud
that doesn't deserve an investigation
the last month that we have to go here
at this point i guess it's 29
30 days this last month is not going to
be calm and boring
it's going to be off the rails
outrageous that's very clear
and on the tail end of this remember as
donald trump is doing this
much of the populist left is talking
about how
aoc might not meet their progressive
purity tests
that's what the left spent their weekend
on as trump is talking about martial law
in the oval office so
earlier in the show we already talked
about that we'll follow up on that
and we will also keep an eye on what
what is happening in the oval office
trump doesn't go out publicly
he's not been seen for i don't even know
weeks now
uh but he's talking about this stuff in
the oval office we'll continue to follow
it
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online
from countless people who have used lucy
to quit
smoking and vaping go check them out at
lucy.co
i've put the link right underneath this
video and you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical